hey what's up this is going to be a
serious video so occasionally uh you'll
forgive me if i'm referencing
the notes because it is an extremely
serious topic let's start with the notes
guys because this is all precipitated as
some of you know because swag academy a
couple days ago
doxed me he revealed my name my former
address he accused me of being the
basically the reincarnation of bill
cosby and r kelly last time i checked r
kelly made beautiful music
nobody listened to him anymore because
of what bill cosby
great actor nobody watches him anymore
because of what when they think of him
they think of what
when you think of coffeezilla you gotta
think of this now um
all based on false information from
anonymous gurus
who were looking to silence me and he
laundered basically blackmail through
his channel to
thousands of people this video is in two
parts the first is gonna be about swag
academy's video on me
uh but the second one is gonna be
talking about the harassment and
blackmail campaign
i've been dealing with and my attempts
to unearth the guys behind it because
ironically they are guys this
guy's saying me too i've been i've been
destroyed by by coffeezilla me too
uh we're gonna talk about that uh anyway
i should i shouldn't
make jokes because it is serious but um
again just been dealing with this for a
long time
and i guess it's finally time to talk
about it so these are two separate
things i'll address them in one video
let's talk about the swag academy video
first the end of coffeezilla as he said
but this guy got to be addressed at one
point you got to get your ass kicked
at one point in time he's clearly some
type of monster abuse and cocaine and
and blackmail and scamming talks that's
not an opinion
i'm not just talking you've abused them
and you're just this monster whereas
this coffeezilla guy is just sarcastic
and he's this loving guy when it comes
to his fan base and all he wants to do
is
help the people stay away from you know
scammers and stuff
it seems like you're the real scammer
you're a fraud you got companies saying
he scammed them
you got ex-girlfriends saying he abused
them all of your subscribers who just
blindly follow you for that matter what
should they do
unsubscribe from you you should delete
your channel all of that because
by the looks of all these articles you
are some crazy monster portraying
yourself to be somebody else
right after the video came up i
immediately told him look
these things are completely false i can
prove that they are false i did prove it
and he
to his enormous credit took it down two
hours
um and has apologized profusely saying
he was in the wrong
and he made an apology he goes all in
all a coffee i apologize for blasting
wrong information i sincerely mean that
i was a million percent wrong on him
talking about me
being who he is which deserves an
enormous
apology i appreciate that so
that said we still need to address a few
things in this video before we move on
to like the
people who are actually doing this the
first thing is why did swag academy
go off on me i want to talk about this
he says i made
four accusations which caused him to
need to respond
some of his accusations were i have a
fake live account
i'm a fake forex guru the comparison
with baby pips and that i'm some type of
scammer
here's the crazy thing of all the things
he says i accused him of only one of
those is true
the only thing i did in that video and
you can verify this anytime you want
is i did compare his course to baby pips
but i never
said in my course review of him that he
was a forex scammer i never said he was
a fake guru and i never said
he was trading fake forex accounts and
the closest thing i came to accusing him
of what he's saying i accused him of was
at the end of the video
here it is if you've taken his course
what did you think is he faking his
metatrader four account five account i
don't know it's impossible to say
but what i can say is i haven't seen
enough evidence to know he's legit
i want to be clear that's not calling
him a scammer it's not calling him a
fake forex guru it's not even saying
he's a fake traitor
i'm just saying what i'm saying i
haven't seen enough evidence i'm
withholding judgment because
these things are easy to fake yeah i
haven't seen enough evidence to know
he's legit these things are so easy to
fake
by the way anyone who's legit shouldn't
be intimidated by that like you should
be happy to show more proof
right like oh boom i got you but the
video starts with him
trying to de-platform me saying i should
never be basically allowed back online
and accusing me of being like r kelly
and bill cosby if you support me
just know that once this video is done
if you're still subscribed to him if
you're still following him if you are
still in support
of him you are the problem too because
you're giving him a platform
a platform he doesn't deserve now listen
i try to be careful with what i say so
if you're gonna say this
i can take criticism i can't take
blasphemous hate
you better be right because where's the
blasphemous hate
in my video was it this you know besides
the name besides the goofy stuff
he's likable and he breaks it down at a
fundamental level
ironically in his anger he's the one who
ended up spewing blasphemous hate about
me nothing i said was even in that same
solar system
that's it i'm gonna go ahead and rate
this a two stars uh for me a little bit
better than tai lopez of course
swaggy sees more likable the course was
broken down i thought a little bit
better
but overall dude just go to baby pips
free i can take
criticism no i don't think you can take
criticism
when i criticized you you doxed me
and dug up every possible thing didn't
bother to validate if any of it was true
and said basically i was the spawn of r
kelly
without first asking me if right when
you're about to accuse me of a crime
if any of it was true all the while
you're saying i accused you of things
that i never accused you of now there's
nowhere to go
positively with this so we're just gonna
have to end it there and for me
right now this is over at the end of the
day this is not drama these are
like serious things uh that are
seriously wrong
false he took it back he apologized
uh to me and my wife he removed the
video and that's all you can do in a
horrible situation like this
um but now we're gonna shift gears a
little bit and talk about the
much worse problem
swag academy he it was a big swing and a
mess with the cough
exposed coffeezilla because he his
information was completely wrong
um but it was all a part of a larger
harassment and blackmail thing that i've
been receiving for
one or multiple gurus i don't know that
yet uh who i've exposed in the past
they're very angry now
and i know you guys are gonna want me to
speculate on who did this as we go
through this information as we unveil
things
but it would be wildly irresponsible for
me to speculate on that because i truly
do not know yet i
am still investigating as of the time of
swag academy's video the plan initially
was to find out who did this you know
make a whole documentary on this
complete insanity
but um unfortunately my hand was kind of
tipped here so i
i didn't find out who did it before i'm
sort of forced to make this video
addressing all these things
and yeah so i'm not going to accuse
anybody yet
but we know sort of the group who did
this maybe
we don't know exactly who it was though
so buckle up guys get your popcorn let
my pain be
your entertainment i guess so the first
post in this like time frame of
harassment is a little fuzzy
i remember it being like really early in
2020 i don't remember exactly when
but it was a little bit after the stefan
james video i remember
like a couple weeks maybe a month after
that i started seeing these websites pop
up
that i've never seen before with my name
in them and they're written by these
anonymous posters
but they have my full name and i'm like
i don't know who these people are right
and but they're accusing me of stuff and
it's like all these posts
are all written by like
i mean i'm gonna say women they're
written by men but the names are
it's like jessica jessica s
uh rachel r right karen
k or whatever like insert name random
name generator
female here uh and these people are
accusing me
things from like small things to
gigantic crazy like world shattering
things all on different anonymous sites
where it's impossible to know who posted
these things
and uh it ranges all the way from bad
website design
that i scam someone as a web developer
all the way to
cocaine abuse to violence against women
okay too literal i kid you not
but at this point i know several things
okay
uh well obviously these are not true
first of all let's just take the first
one i'm not even a web developer i
studied chemical engineering in college
then i started my youtube channel
there's this post where it's like this
guy built the worst
website for our company i've never had a
job as a web developer
so the cocaine story is even funnier
okay
because they they say basically i was i
was hooked on cocaine
which is really funny if you know
anything about me because i didn't even
like drink till i was 21. like i was
that guy
like i'm so milk toast that if i was
accused of anything
in high school or even college it was
like yeah that guy's like kind of like
he doesn't really go out too much
he doesn't really party but like the
fact that they're trying to paint me
as pablo escobar iv is hilarious to me
you know i shouldn't laugh because it's
it's crazy but you do have to appreciate
the irony here
the final thing uh which is the most
serious but also the dumbest
which is a lot of fake accusations of
like women
one look at my dating history disproves
that okay um i've talked about it
multiple times
on the drip on coffeezilla but i've been
in the same relationship
for like 10 years okay i married my high
school sweetheart here look
this is back during the high school date
yeah i was one of those guys
right look at me young young coffeezilla
boys and there's my wife and i didn't
have a costume and she did
and here she is now guys look she's real
like this is something that spencer
cornelia and amish will tease me about
is like ah you haven't like played the
game like i've played the field
and they're right so i don't know it's
so funny because these fake gurus are
apparently typing
in their closet about me and they're i
don't know what are they imagining
like i'm the cross between a james bond
ladies man
a web developer who's apparently very
bad at this job pablo escobar
and then somehow bill cosby all combined
like sorry i'm not that exciting
so even though i i don't know i find it
funny immediately i decided to
start contacting these websites and try
to figure out how i can get get them
taken down because they're lies
uh and this is where i learned a hard
truth
there are these websites which use
freedom of speech as an excuse to let
people anonymously
like post crazy stuff about anyone
and if you want to challenge them and
have them take to take it down
you have to pay thousands of dollars in
arbitration which is
fancy language for blackmail yeah
we have this crazy thing written about
you by someone who hates you
um pay us money to take it down
thousands of dollars
and so look guys i'm not rich
and frankly my reputation's not worth
thousands of dollars
uh so i just don't have money to pay for
this expensive stuff
and honestly here's the other problem if
you do take it down
they're just gonna post again about you
and then they know it's like affecting
you anyway
so i'm like you know what i guess
let's try to find out who's doing it so
that we can expose who's doing this but
like there's nothing i can do
sort of objectively about the fact that
people can just post
crazy things on these crazy websites
cranberry break
ah but i want to make it clear
okay um i want to make it clear how easy
it is to do this stuff
so i could write a review right now
about i could take all the stuff
that swag academy found about me and i
think he found like most of the posts
that are up there
and i could take those those accusations
i could copy and paste them i could put
them in the exact same websites under an
anonymous name
you know like samantha w or something
like that and i could just replace my
name
with mother teresa or you know queen of
england
and those people just like me would have
nothing to do no option no way to take
it down
besides pay thousands of dollars and
then even if they do that
you could just put up another one and
another one and another one now i would
never
ever do that i think it's the most
reprehensible thing you can do
but that's the reality of the internet
um these websites
let people post anything and then they
extort you for money
and i didn't want to address it in the
community because they doxed all this
personal stuff about me so to address it
is to dox myself and so i wasn't about
to do that and i guess
that that has been kind of forced
because
swag academy did it but um you know it
just is what it is
so at this point you know i'm realizing
that i need documentation
for when eventually people come to me i
need to prove to them like of course
this is false like i could
i could show them basic stuff you know i
i could show you you know my wife
uh we've been together forever that's
obviously not true
but the thing is is that i wanted more
concrete evidence because you
literally cannot have enough concrete
evidence to fight off
baseless things like this so the first
thing i learned while
starting to document this stuff is that
i'm not the only one
who has gone through this this is like a
regular thing
with people who have a platform who you
know have an audience
especially if they talk about serious
issues recently a video came out
called down the rabbit hole where nexbo
who's a youtuber tells the story of
multiple youtubers with very big
platforms
being the target of a harassment
campaign take a listen
the reputation damage that someone can
cause with these claims are enough to
give anyone crippling anxiety
especially when people are unaware of
the context of what's actually happening
it isn't just me either mama max mudahar
loewy lane and night docs have all
fallen victim to this online plague
anyone online who just likes you they
can post things online without proof
completely anonymously
so i became obsessed with trying to find
the person harassing me like this
and right about now is when i got this
email
you have ruined the lives of your close
ones now this email address is
5ymail.com which bills itself as a
anonymous email provider
so we can't trace it it's time stamped
march 8th 2020. so like i said
soon after sort of this stuff started
happening um and
in it it has the names of friends of
people who's like sort of like distantly
related to me and family
and even people who came on my channel
who i'm not even close to
like todd baldwin roger wakefield like i
had him on one time on the show
this guy says all going to be trashed on
internet for life
you literally ruin their lives with your
adventures in a few
days entire internet will be filled with
your stories thousands of articles you
can't remove this in your lifetime
i at this point you know i'm kind of
thinking like did somebody pay
um somebody abroad to just like write a
ton of bad articles about me like this
this sounds like the ultimate fake guru
move like not only do you
like defame somebody and hide behind an
anonymous email
you outsource it like don't have time to
ruin someone else's life with basis
allegations
pay someone to do it for you it's
ridiculous uh
now i'm gonna go out of the limb and
call this what it is like this is evil
stuff
you know you can make a video about me
you can disagree with me that's fine but
try to threaten innocent people just
because they're connected with me just
because i talked
about your goofy course like it's insane
and it goes to the pathology of the
people i talk about i tell you guys all
the time like
these these alphas right these guys who
are
so successful they sure have sensitive
egos it's very interesting
now after this email i knew obviously
who i'm dealing with is clearly
unstable uh so i emailed around to these
forums
now with this email and i wanted to show
them proof that like i'm being harassed
and i
asked them like can you take it down
please this is not a normal case
one of these platforms reaches back out
and they say um oh no we can't take it
down
this is somewhere around late april at
this point
and i'm gonna have to blur a lot of this
for reasons i'll explain a second but he
says yeah i'm not gonna take this down
but i can i can see a couple of familiar
names
friends who are listed on your channel
would you be willing to consider
a swap removal meaning i sw
delete one of my videos and he deletes
false criminal
allegations okay don't ask me how it's
gonna help me i won't make a penny out
of it but it could secure some vital
promotion
from an agency concerned now to be clear
this is
a pure blackmail i respond
who which videos would constitute the
swap removal you're referring to
he says i don't know the links but it's
dan lok
two videos dated back to 2019. i
immediately know which videos he's
talking about they're
victims who came forward to me and um
they talked about their experience in
htc so
i even have a double like sense of
responsibility to keep those videos out
because not only are they my videos but
they're actually someone else's
testimony
and then this person wants me to take
them down
all so that i can basically get
something that's not true taken down
about me
it's just crazy so now you guys know by
the way because this is the same time
that the trim black stuff was happening
why i was so eager to help him when he
was getting doxed and blackmailed
because he got dachshunds blackmailed on
april 29th
all this was happening on april 27th
like same time frame
it's so messed up it's so horrible like
you guys think that this is easy to do
it's not there's a reason not many
people are doing this because
you get into it and you realize holy
like you have to deal with the worst
kind of people
the absolute worst kind of people on
earth now this email continues right
i could perhaps use this to help my
network as well as provide you a removal
as an exception and perhaps give you the
information of the users behind the
posts and comments now needless to say i
would appreciate you
and me keep this confidential even if we
end up not going through this
at all now uh i'll just cut to the chase
i didn't do it which is why i don't have
the information of the people
he's talking about however the reason
that i blurt all this out and the reason
that i'm keeping his name confidential
is because at the end of the day he did
do the right thing
even though i didn't remove my dan lok
testimonials
um he did end up going back and removing
these things i mean
he saw it just as plain as day i emailed
him probably like 50 times after that
he saw playing his day that this is all
fake he saw like
these crazy you know things coming
through he probably saw
that it was the same email putting each
one in so
he removed it he literally this guy who
runs one of these websites which
job is how they make money is by
basically bribing you to take stuff
false stuff down about yourself this is
the guy who says you know what this is
this is too crazy even for me these are
completely false
and i really appreciate him for that um
and that's why i'm blurring it out
because
you know he's the only person in this
situation who really did
a good thing here and so i want to pay
him that respect uh now the final piece
of information that's the wildest at one
point in 2020 i tried to catfish these
guys
you know and prove that it's gurus uh by
leaving an email address on one of these
websites like where i was basically like
oh i got crazy info
you know and i i recorded myself doing
this all right ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the weirdest thing
ever where we catfish ourselves
to catch to catch a predator uh this is
weird so
this guy docks me on the i don't know if
it's a guy somebody docks me on the
internet and put all these like insane
accusations out there but they're all on
an anonymous site
so it's impossible to know who they are
right
right
and so they're like blatantly untrue but
we're like how do we discover who's
doing this
because we don't have their email
address so i so you came over the idea
that basically we should accuse kind of
ourselves
of something of something that sounds
juicy and then leave the email there so
that whoever this
is who probably wants real evidence
against us because obviously it's just
made up
would contact us and we could unearth
who's actually behind us so here's our
little thing here crazy story we'll see
if anyone bites
on the catfish all right
man i look terrible without a beard huh
um now a long time went by from that
i was like i i don't know if that was in
march or april i'm not so sure on the
timeline here but um we get a bite
cali duvet555 gmail.com emails
now does that sound familiar to you it
should
because let's go back to the swag video
right he says that one of the women
is named cali there's another girl who
commented a few months later in july
saying hey jessica stefan is not a good
dude let's just say that
totally get where you are coming from
don't want to say a lot more hair
publicly
let's compare notes let's compare notes
like
if if girls can say we're going to
compare notes that means it must have
happened to her too
now what's the email address there kali
edwards 555
gmail.com huh i wonder if there's any
relation
it's just a guy trying to make a bunch
of different sock puppet email accounts
so it doesn't seem like it's the same
but
they forgot to substantially change the
name cali duvet
cali edwards 555 the same
um so what does this girl
say right who's this girl who says i'm
not a good dude
let's just say that what do they say the
first thing they say
right when they go to my catfish email
thinking they're gonna get something
juicy
hey i represent one of the people steven
has attacked
via his youtube channel i don't even
know what to say
at every corner it's angry gurus who
can't prove they're legitimate who can't
defend their
insane prices who can't explain why
victims are coming out left and right
and they have to resort to these insane
tactics right
uh now i sent this guy an ip tracker and
this is where it led me
according to most of the ip geolocators
i found it's pittsburgh pennsylvania now
i can't speculate beyond that uh who's
behind this but what i can tell you is
beyond a shadow of a doubt
this is a hundred percent a smear
campaign designed to
shut me up and created by a lot of the
gurus that i talk about
and um basically they think if they can
make enough
false things about me up then i'll stop
saying true things about them
but it's not gonna work and it's very
sad
that um you know these people feel like
they need to resort to this rather than
just coming on my show
and just talking about it now honestly
the only part about this that upsets me
really
you know this late in the game of course
initially i was upset
who wouldn't be right but there comes to
this point where you realize
oh this is how the public eye works like
there's nothing i can do
this happens to other youtubers it's not
just nexpo and a bunch of other
youtubers
you know i've got a buddy matt tabor
it's happened to so many people at this
point it's not even funny
the internet can be a very like dark
place
but the thing that really upsets me here
is not really that
is that this stuff delegitimizes real
victims coming forward with real stories
because you have to account
for the kind of psychopaths who are
going to use the pain
of real victims with real crimes
committed against them
to try to win some imaginary beef it's
very sad
and i feel very bad for the people who
are so twisted with what they're doing
their business
that this is the kind of like black hat
stuff that they stoop to
again i'm not calling out names i'm just
saying
we know the general cast of characters i
do not know who did it i just know the
group
generally one of these guys did this
anyways that's basically my story i hope
uh it's not really that fun but um
i hope you now have a better idea of
what's going on
not only with what's going on behind the
scenes in my life i don't like to talk
about it because
i feel like you guys probably don't care
too much but
i hope it gives you a better perspective
um you know please don't go harass
anybody
that's not my intention here my
intention is to simply explain to you
what's been going on
that we're up against some crazy stuff
crazy people
and you know that really means the world
to me that you guys
support me so thank you very much
appreciate you
i'll see you in the next one